let's say that you were standing in a
forest let's make it a really diverse
one you know the amazon
every creature that you see
is the result of a three and a half
billion year winning streak of
reproduction and for almost every
creature that you see that winning
streak is about to come to an end right
that's just statistically true most
creatures are dead ends very soon but by
virtue of their having arrived here we
know that they have never lost till this
point right they've arrived
that's why evolution is so effective
right it's effective because of that
massive edit each and every generation
that eliminates all but the ones in
which the best characteristics and good
luck have come together and gotten them
one more time through this intense
bottleneck right
so evolution is very powerful process
for that reason because of the constant
massive editing
economics isn't quite that effective but
it has the same characteristic now when
we say that a creature
fits into a niche
what do we mean
what we mean is that there is some
abstraction some way to exist
that it that is there and creatures by
exploring that space right those
creatures with a little bit more of this
a little bit longer limbs right a little
bit
more acute eyes whatever it is
longer snouts whatever it happens to be
the creatures come to fit that niche in
the same way that a liquid comes to fit
the shape of whatever container you put
it in so the point is evolution whether
it's economic or biotic explores the
shapes of containers and it tells us
what the shape of the container is by
what works what sticks what we see there
and
all right
the reason this comes up
is i was for the third time in
a
short number of weeks
confronted by
the system for covid testing that one
has to engage in to participate in
certain activities these are tests that
you source within a certain number of
hours before you get on a plane or
attend an event or in cases in portland
some places you would have to do it to
go to a restaurant if you can't prove
you're vaccinated
most recently to get
toby admission to camp yes toby
admission to camp um
we have also done it and i've now done
it in three countries i've done it in
the u.s a couple times i've done it in
britain and we've done it in the bahamas
each time the experience is the same
it's
very
um
bureaucratic
but surprisingly efficient strange
talking about covet testing makes us
both cough
yeah it does
but but the point is
one goes in and one fears that somebody
is going to jam a snap a swab way up
into your sinuses but in fact it's not
it doesn't go in so deep in fact they'll
hand you the swab and you'd do it
yourself
and
it does raise a question i mean for one
thing
you and i have both had covet i have yet
to successfully test positive we know
that we've had covid because for example
you and i one of us gave it to the other
and then you lost your sense of smell i
had an osmium right which is really the
good test yeah um but you know at least
for the antigen tests it didn't come up
positive for us so that's interesting
lab work is difficult these tests are
not particularly good in fact one of the
things that we don't know is how good
these tests even are and good at what
are they how good are they for one
variant to the next right we don't know
these questions
but
the point that i want to make is that
there is a niche now for a service
that service ostensibly is about testing
for covid and in principle this is a
good idea
covett is a dangerous disease right much
more dangerous than the case fatality
rate would have you understand
trying to control its spread is a good
idea knowing who has it is a good
element in a program to control its
spread from one part of the country to
the next from one country to the next it
makes sense but what has emerged in this
niche
is a racket right a low quality testing
service that is very expensive right the
tests in the us cost 300 bucks a pop if
you need them
on short notice and you do need them on
short notice because people say you need
it within
48 hours of travel and in principle
that's a good idea
right so that you have a good sense that
everybody who arrives has just tested
negative and therefore is likely to
remain negative
you know in principle it's a great idea
but the point is what you've got
is something that is exploring the
dimensions
of this niche and one of the elements of
this niche is that it is going to reward
poor testing
rather than high quality testing
if you have covet you test negative you
go to whatever the event is and it turns
into a super spreader event what are the
chances that anybody is tracking which
lab failed to detect your coconut
right so the point is the incentive yeah
on top of the event now having a super
spreader event to mitigate the
downstream effects of they're going to
go and do due diligence on every single
person's covet test no they're not right
they're not
once exist but somebody would have you'd
have to set up something like an agency
in order to figure out which labs were
more likely to miss active covid right
you would need a series of super
spreader events and then you would chase
them back to potentially organizations
that had run the test badly to protocols
that didn't work right but no such
oversight appears to exist anywhere and
so the point is and without which i mean
this is where you're going without which
it's it's pure theater it's worse than
pure theater because what it does is it
inhabits the space that's a good
defensive theater though it's lucrative
lucrative yeah it's expensive for us
fills the space in the environment where
a good testing program would go so if
you had the idea of well you know what
it would be really great if we had good
labs that gave good tests especially hey
maybe even at a good price
right well the question is
economically speaking which of these
things is going to win that niche
right is it the one where you're likely
to get an a test that says you're
coveted positive is it the very
sensitive high quality test that's going
to win out probably not because if
you're in the position of getting one of
these tests then you know you're rooting
for a negative result right you want to
go to the thing you want to get on the
airplane you want to go to the place
that you've got reservations you don't
want a positive test and so the point is
there is competition to deliver you an
answer that you want that is going to
increase the number of super spreader
events it's going to increase the amount
of covet the difficulty of controlling
it the number of variants that are going
to circulate around the world and if you
tried to do it right you would lose in
competition with these folks who have
that niche filled right and so yeah this
is this is a place where market forces
fail us
well let's put it this way they don't
have to well they have right because
all of the testing centers um within a
particular geographic area are in direct
competition with one another and so that
that testing center which had access to
or did due diligence on actually doing a
more reliable providing more reliable
test results
and thus providing fewer false negatives
would lose in competition would lose in
competition and there's a question about
how far up the scales in other words the
system that created the niche how
interested in it is it in controlling
kovid versus appearing to be very active
in controlling kovid without bothering
and you know it bears mention that at
least one part of the system is making
so much money from covid that it has a
perverse incentive right is the moral
decency of the people in charge of
pharma so good that it overwhelms their
fiscal benefit from uh not controlling
covet and delivering
lousy remedies that are expensive and
mandated and paid for by government
right i don't know maybe they're
exceedingly good people but all of them
all of them right or you know even if
you even if you imagine that that's true
all right so you have multiple companies
let's say nine out of ten are run by
exceedingly moral people who just would
never think about somehow their boards
are cool with this their boards are cool
even though it is a violation of their
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders but all it takes is the one
company that isn't run by those people
one company that's just simply run by
business people right and that company
will win and then it will take over the
industry so basic point is hey look you
get whatever the niche is right you you
don't expect when you pour
water into a glass you don't expect it
to inhabit half the glass and leave half
the glass empty it will fill whatever
shape you've given it and the point is
the niches are what they are
the businesses will discover the shape
of the niche those that are better able
to explore and figure out where the
opportunities are that aren't so cool
but nonetheless are lucrative those
businesses will will win out in
competition and so we get these things
so check this out though um i just read
and i
i don't think i figured out where it is
before our show here today but i just
read that as of tomorrow as of june 12th
the cdc has declared and i question why
the cdc gets to declare anything
anytime anywhere never again but like i
just don't think they have the authority
they're not that kind of an agency but
the cdc has declared that as of june
12th
people coming to the us do not need to
have a negative covet test
which is interesting in light of all of
this
that the u.s is saying yep or i don't
know if the us is saying the cdc is
saying
uh the thing's changed this is this is
no longer a necessary part of the
protocol
right which could mean a lot of
different things it could be you know so
my claim is that the uh kova testing
regime is a racket
right yes the idea is it looks like a
kova testing regime but really it's a
rubber stamping mechanism where you get
you pay 300 bucks for the rubber stamp
um and the chances that they catch uh
you know your active infection are
you know at least lower than they should
be it reminds me of getting research
permits in uh
tropical countries back when
back when i was actively doing
you didn't have to do it as much as you
were often working within
a field station that took care of a lot
of the logistics for you but i ended up
having to get independent permits
in three different countries in latin
america and madagascar and you were
there for some of the wrangling with
bureaucrats in madagascar you know i got
asked for things like i literally got
asked for a land rover like at that
point i made thirteen thousand dollars a
year like do i look like i have a land
rover
but
uh it doesn't hurt it doesn't hurt to
ask yeah and you know one day we were
told to come back yet again because the
guy with the rubber stamp was gone the
next day though the guy was there but
the key to the office uh was with
someone else and then like it just went
on and on but anyway yeah the rubber
stamping uh it this this rubber stamping
reminds me of uh incoherent uh
bureaucratic procedures
in very poor countries where local dudes
are just trying to make a buck
yes the problem is in the banana
republic's so-called yeah you can see
this right and the the irony of the
power of the guy with the rubber stamp
and the fact that the guy with the
rubber stamp makes so little money that
it would be impossible if somebody's
going to extract a million dollars of
lumber out of a forest they're not
supposed to be cutting lumber from and
the person who has the rubber stamp
makes ten thousand dollars a year it's
not hard to change that guy's picture
enough that he'll look the other way
yeah so if i mean that that's that at
least when i was working in madagascar
that that number would have been way
lower yeah you know just madagascar was
so poor like so yes a land rover was a
very big ask
um but i believe in that case i came
back with a bottle of johnny walker and
you know that was that was good that was
sufficient yeah so um but i wanted to
point to a
shinier fancier version of a closely
related racket because really my point
is you can see it with the covet thing
it's new enough and because we're
interacting with it and learning what
this system looks like it's like oh this
couldn't possibly work right
but
there are other versions of it so one of
them that surprised me during
the
the covid pandemic
was the discovery of how
the
testing the safety testing of
pharmaceuticals actually works and you
know this is the second time i've
encountered weirdness in that realm the
first time being about telomeres and
mouse evolution which
i will just point out
the story there i don't want to go too
deep because it would take a lot of
explaining but i discovered as a
graduate student
that the mice in the colonies that
supply
our scientific establishment including
our drug safety testing
apparatus those mice had evolved
to the container formed by the market
for laboratory mice and so the point was
look if you're going to breed laboratory
mice you want to produce as many mice
per unit of effort and shelter and food
as you can and that economic pressure to
produce new mice as cheaply as possible
causes breeders to breed young mice and
not old mice and that simple fact
elongated the telomeres of mice and gave
them essentially no protection from
tumors and a essentially infinite
capacity to replace damaged tissue which
is a selective force that effectively
moved all of the negative effects of all
the drugs that were being tested into
later stages of life right and so the
problem when i discovered that and i
discovered it i predicted it from theory
carol grider then tested it and
established that indeed wild mice did
not have long telomeres which was not
obvious at the time
but the point was when i found that
i naively believed that what would
happen next is everybody would go
and they would realize that their
science was all polluted by the mice
they had been using and that their drug
safety testing was allowing dangerous
drugs to make it to market and there was
going to be a massive effort to retest
drugs a massive effort to figure out how
this had polluted what we understood
about wound healing and aging and cancer
and everything else and it didn't happen
right now i think
so why why the crickets
one reason i believe is that
pharma and everything connected to it
realized that it had a mechanism for
making drugs that weren't especially
safe look very safe in fact if you give
a poisonous drug to a mouse that's going
to die of cancer but has an infinite
capacity for repair if the poison isn't
so poisonous that it kills the mouse
outright it may actually make them live
longer because it functions as
chemotherapy since cancer
cells are in the process of always
dividing they are more vulnerable than
regular cells and so that is a result
i've seen several times where a drug
paradoxically makes the animals live
longer and seems super great but the
point is no that won't translate to
humans
nonetheless the point is the mice
adapted to an economic niche
which has very real biological
consequences
the racket i wanted to point to that
isn't particularly visible right the
covid testing racket is visible to us
the one that surprised me
doesn't surprise me in retrospect but
surprised me when i first came to
understand that it existed
was that when we say
pfizer tested its drug
for safety
that's generally not what we mean pfizer
doesn't test the drug what pfizer does
is it contracts
those who specialize in the testing of
drugs to do these tests and the problem
is if you imagine
an outfit that's awesome at testing
drugs and detecting safety signals that
are really important versus one that
sucks at it by design the point is
pfizer has an interest in finding the
one that's going to give it the
equivalent of the rubber stamp and so
there's economic competition even if
pfizer didn't know what it was doing
right to the extent that it gives
business to those that have a protocol
that is most likely to miss safety
signals right then that
it means that pfizer doesn't have its
fingerprints on it it means uh that its
drug makes it to market because it looks
safer than it is and this is especially
true in the case where you've got uh
immunity from liability right because
there's no way for the system to come
back and correct it so the evolution of
protocols that don't work
that's what you're going to get if the
shape of the container is such that it
rewards those protocols which we can see
you know how many other places are there
i've now described two right the mouse
version is a third
so how many places has the shape of the
container caused us to put together
something that looks like a scientific
protocol that just doesn't do what it's
supposed to do the two that you
described are the kova testing coveted
testing
uh the running of clinical trials to see
how safe and effective
drugs are
where the companies that actually do
that work
are
uh rewarded for pleasing their employers
right or their those who have contracted
them
uh and then the mouse thing i believe
happened inadvertently i'm yeah all but
certain that nobody planned that but
having discovered that it existed the
incentive to get rid of that and get
mice that could actually tell you when a
drug was dangerous that incentive wasn't
there yeah no i mean certainly in the
case of the mice by far the most
parsimonious uh explanation for how
those breeding protocols got started was
just simple economics simple like well
in fact that is reflected by the fact
when i found that i went looking because
that has nothing to do with mice or
science what it has to do with is any
protocol in a small it has to be a small
animal it won't work with a large one
because a large one will get cancer and
won't live to reproduce
but in a small enough animal if you
breed for economic efficiency you get
this result and so we've seen it in mice
rats asian hamsters mongolian gerbils
yeah right like there's some hamsters oh
is that mongolian gerbils is that the
same thing i'm agnostic
okay um i know there's just there's a
lot of uh anyway doesn't matter um there
are there are a few of these uh
what was the oh you said chickens
chickens yeah i was so a few rodents and
i guess a bird
that uh should happen where we see uh a
species basically being
designed with some intentionality um to
be a good lab animal
right
really it's you know them anytime the
intention is to be a good lab animal and
the the failure is oops complex systems
unintended consequences
um you know antagonistic plyo trophies
which is specifically what you found
with regard to cancer and senescence uh
in uh with regard to telomere length um
which is to say early effects that are
that are good will masculine effects
that are bad
for the same right same gene i mean you
know the basic point is look it should
have been obvious that your
laboratory colony is an environment
every bit as much as a forest or your
basement you know
or a grain silo right and so whatever
the forces are in that environment is
going to shape that critter because you
haven't done anything to reduce the
tendency of those in the colony that are
better adapted to out compete those that
are worse adapted so you're going to get
exactly
which you know which we in quotes uh
took advantage of in doing serial
passaging research and you know gain of
function research with regard to yeah
the intention was not
uh to
to affect the ferrets there if it was
ferrets or whatever it was but actually
specifically to enhance functionality
and um through
uh monitoring mutations and choosing
which ones we liked in for instance
viruses right so um
we at the voice point is we selected for
well presumably if what we seem to be
able to infer from the nature of sarsko
v2 is the result of serial passaging in
tissues and creatures
presumably in
wuhan
those who ran those experiments were
serially passaging them to create
certain changes but they inevitably
selected for other changes they weren't
even thinking about like adaptation to
the laboratory environment adaptation to
be able to jump evolutionary gaps
because they were running it through
different creatures and tissues
potentially adaptation for very rapid
change yeah you know rapid rapid
variance for instance yeah yeah
so anyway um i'm not sure how to sum all
this up except to say
that welcome to complex systems
our environments will cause anything
that has the characteristics of an
evolving
uh lineage or creature
to find
the
shape of the niche and inhabit it which
means you need to be you know if you did
want to fix the testing regime if you
did want to fix uh pharma's um uh
protocols
what you would have to do
is disincentivize
uh rubber stamp
protocols and incentivize the discovery
of information that actually caused
dangerous drugs not to emerge cause
people with covet not to get on
airplanes
those things and it's not inconceivable
that you could build those incentives
but
the problem is
that
those
with
control tend to be those who are
benefiting from the structure as it
stands and so
you know we saw this week
i believe it was um
[Music]
cdc recommending boosters for
five-year-olds
and in fact
the absurdity of this has been described
in public but the basic point was the
whole apparatus is set up to deliver
that answer which is why it delivered
that answer despite the fact that
there's no real medical argument for it
and a very strong argument against it
um and increasingly
actually even hitting the mainstream
mainstream media we have oh higher rates
of covid in fully boosted people than in
you know so-called fully vaccinated
people which like not boosted
right
no but um look
the system is going to evolve if you
give incentives you know capture will
create an incentive for those who are
supposedly regulated to generate a the
equivalent of a rubber stamp upstream of
them you should not be surprised when
that rubber stamp rubber stamps things
right you should expect that and what we
are dealing with is a captured system in
which the shapes of these niches are all
paradoxical because the purpose of those
niches isn't to enhance the public's
health it's to do something else right
basically you get
regulators whose purpose is to enhance
the well-being of the shareholders of
the corporations that have captured the
regulators right
not surprising
right maddening but not surprising
[Music]
you